i have a chat i have a chapter on this
in the book and i talk about how
uh the the most manic of of these
individuals
uh are according to research are
incredibly uh
anti-social and they can't tell if it's
the chicken or the egg
is it their own beliefs and ideologies
that make them antisocial or is it
something
about them that makes them that way and
when you look at what's going on
in this in the streets of portland and
seattle there's
there is a mental issue going on there
they do not
seem stable so i think that these are
people that have lost contact
with their loved ones their family i
don't think these are people that come
home for thanksgiving
and help with the turkey
so as a guy that just wrote a you know a
self-help it's a self-help
mockery in a way but it's also but it is
self-help at the same time
what do you think it is about that type
like what do you think the dividing line
is between a type of person who wants to
take care of themselves and their life
versus the type of person that wants to
because we see so much of this
everywhere
just take out other people
well i have a chat i have a chapter on
this in the book and i talk about how
the most manic of of these individuals
uh are according to research are
incredibly uh
anti-social and they can't tell if it's
the chicken or the egg
is it their own beliefs and ideologies
that make them anti-social or is this
something
about them that makes them that way and
when you look at what's going on
in this in the streets of portland and
seattle there's
there is a mental issue going on there
they do not
seem stable so i think that these are
people that have lost contact
with their loved ones their family i
don't think these are people that come
home for thanksgiving
and help with the turkey right i think
that their
joy in life is to humiliate
and attack and have you hear their their
screams and their cries
i do think that it's we're living in an
age of hysteria
and i think it's also bleeding into
other certain segments
that i can't even talk about certain
activists
who do not represent the people they
claim to
there's a great um oh there's a great
clip of this african-american
cop in portland talking about how a
black activist came up to him and said
hey you know um you know how do you feel
about george floyd as he's talking
a white leftist female comes over and
goes don't talk to him
she's telling a black woman not to talk
to him it's and you realize
okay this is a this is a mental issue
this is uh
so i think that you almost have to pull
them out of this cult
you and i aren't in cults because the
measure of a cult is the ability to
admit when you're wrong
like i admit i'm wrong on like at least
once or twice a year no once or twice
like
pretty regularly um uh well not only do
you admit greg not only do you admit
you're wrong
can you tell the good people what
happened this very week on the greg
gutfeld show with you and cows
you made a major a major admission yes
uh a mission nice one or omission
emission
um i might have that
i've noticed this that
um we all have and even adams has said
this but he won't admit what what what
mistakes
that we have these like really
embarrassing things
that we that we won't voice because
we're for example
in seinfeld it was george costanza
didn't want to go to a flea market
because he thought there were fleas i
always thought that
i thought that too there were flea
markets in belmont california and my
friends were running oh i'm not going
there because i thought police so
two i have two idiotic beliefs in the
last
uh month that i've talked about one on
the five i thought
veal was a separate animal i didn't know
that it was like a baby cow
no idea i thought like when you ordered
veal it's like ordering lamb
or it's just a different animal so
that's embarrassing but i didn't know
that cows were only female i thought
that a cow was just like there was a
male
so that's stupid but it's like i i don't
mind confessing that i know these things
i i'm an idiot because i know for a fact
that
everybody everybody
feels that way i mean there are people
that think that there might be 52 states
uh because they get confused between a
deck of cards and the united states and
also you have those two states
that are outside sometimes i'm going
like is it 52 or 50.
52 or 50. i should check because i get
confused
you know is it 48 plus 2 it's 48 plus 2.
also there are things like when you
think about geography in general that
you can get stuff totally wrong
because uh you kind of skipped over it
and somebody could trick you into
thinking that something was part of
something when it really wasn't
um there are parts of europe that i
might have thought were parts of other
places
but is all of that is all of that really
just because everyone seems to pretend
that they know everything at all times
net neutrality was going to kill
everybody soleimani's death was going to
start world war three
yes you know there's some the russia
thing the ukraine thing with the iran
nuclear deal people who
have no jobs no people who can't get
their lives together but they know
everything about string theory and
economic policy and everything yes
i try to do that you know who knows
every i'm convinced who
knows everything according to his fans
is john oliver
man did you see his his 30 minute on net
neutrality it'll change your life it's
like
no thanks i'd rather be ignorant i don't
i don't think i need to know 30 minutes
on net neutrality because i know where
it's going to end up
in the same place it always does and to
your point it's always the same place
and i think it's helpful like
like string theory this is this is the
blessing and cursive podcast
that you could do your curriculum i'm
going to learn about quantum physics
at quantum mechanics or quantum gravity
you put quantum in front of everything
and suddenly people like who is this guy
but i enjoy
quantum leap yes i love that actor
there was scott bakula scott bakula and
oh the other guy
who played tom who played booth uh who
played mr booth in blue velvet
who was he was in green hair the boy was
in the movie boy with green hair
he was in air force one i just watched
it this weekend uh
he's stu uh god geez louise if only
somebody here could google the boy with
green hair
that did you see that movie as a kid
do you ever see that movie zapoy wakes
up with green hair i don't think i've
seen it
oh very scary amazing i saw it as a
child probably came out in the 1940s
1950s
but the guy we're talking about stuart
stu
stan
uh george we should do you know what i'm
gonna do wait greg watch this i'm gonna
do something i've never done this on my
show before but my director is remote
right now
he's in my ear matt i want you to google
the actor that we're talking about he
was in quantum leap he was not scott
bakula but the other guy
and apparently he had green hair as a
child can you get me that actor's name
this is the most cable news i've ever
been right now yeah and he was the guy
that ran the bordello
dean stockwell dean stockwell
i hope he's still alive dean stockwell
did you ever see blue velvet wait hold
on let me go back to the control room
matt is dean stockwell still alive yes
stand by greg
i hope he is
still alive no wow he's 84 and still
alive at least as of this taping
road trip we are going on a steam stop
did you
i have to ask you because my favorite
movie of all time is blue velvet
and dean stockwell's character was the
guy that ran the whorehouse
that dennis hopper came to and it's one
of the greatest scenes
in any movie um anyway that's my did you
what you look like you've not seen blue
velvet
i actually i i haven't seen it believe
it or not but gut felt i got to tell you
i love you but your movie
recommendations over the last couple
months have really been disastrous
i'm talking about i'm texting you one
morning i'm like i don't know what we're
going to watch
tonight i've watched everything you're
like oh you got to watch the color of
something with nick cage i literally i
got brain damage in the middle of the
movie it was that hard
whoa whoa whoa whoa so wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute that's the
protocol
with the color of space
no no no not the color of space it's
it's a remake
the uh the um officer the um
i can't swear right now because of you
um no you can square it i swear
people will like it okay so it was a
remake of a harvey keitel movie
but it really wasn't and it's called
porto call and it's by the guy who did
grizzly man
um the director um who did grizzly man
werner herzog did it and it's called um
cop officer
bad lieutenant porter call and it's got
iguanas in it
how could you not love that movie how
could you not love that movie
then this cage it's one of nick cage's
best films dick cage
also if you've ever seen you didn't like
mandy did you mandy where are you no
i tried to watch that because of you too
i watched it for about a half hour and i
couldn't take it anymore i was sitting
in a pool of my own vomit
and i thought i got felt that's
wednesday
[Laughter]
this is what you call a tangent this is
the beauty of youtube
that you don't have the luxury as a
cable news host
to do these do these things um actually
i i want to tell you about something
somewhat serious actually because just
in the last couple days
uh you know tucker did this end of the
show monologue
about what the new york times is doing
right now and they've basic they've
basically
threatened to dox him they already did
one version of this and we know that
people have shown up at his house before
and all that
uh i feel that this is the next level of
where this is all going that they've
said it's okay to burn down stores
violence isn't violence
words are violence but violence is and
it's very confusing but the next level
of this will be that
it will be it will be something to the
effect of
can republicans go to public places
right and can republicans have homes
that are not doxxed are you worried
about that like what what do you make of
this thing
oh um i'm worried in a number of ways
that i've actually acted on it
uh for the last couple of years actually
i've acted on
uh on certain things to to for safety
reasons and and we've talked about that
before
um i find it interesting that all the
things that you talked about are okay
but they're charging that couple for
brandishing that weapon
when the mob broke down the gate and was
in front of their house
so they're actually telling you not only
can you be threatened
not only can your uh public and private
property be vandalized
but you cannot defend yourself if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell